all right I want to talk about Kim
Kardashian's ass yeah there it is right
there that is a giant what is that
that's a human ass like look at that
thing it is giant and glossy and I've
never seen an ass like that before and I
want to talk about Kim Kardashian's ass
because everybody is talking about Kim
Kardashian's ass actually if you go on
Twitter right this very second hashtag
break the internet because that's how
big they think this thing is gonna be no
pun intended and there's all kinds of
funny memes going on and on about it so
the Kardashians let's talk about the
Kardashians for a second because I think
they represent something truly truly
terrible awful in this country
look the dad the dad Kardashian he was a
lawyer he I guess he helped get OJ off
wonderful guy you know doing God's work
and then they just became this really
rich family and the reality show and the
sex tape I guess the reality show is
still on they sleep with a lot of dudes
some basketball players and rappers and
blah blah blah and there is something
about this family that I think we must
stop they are part you know reality TV
came along and we lost a lot of
wholesome goodness of like sitcoms and
family things and then what they just
showed us this raw awful manipulative
nonsense
and so much of what they do trickles
down to kids look at that ass again do
you want your wife or your your daughter
or your girlfriend's asked to look like
that are people digging this ass I know
part here our cameraman he's digging
this ass but I'm really this is why is
this why are we all looking at Kim
Kardashian's butt today and you may say
Dave you're showing us Kim Kardashian's
ass while you're saying this but this is
an auntie Kim Kardashian ass video not a
pro Kim Kardashian ass video if that's
at all possible I know that's quite
controversial anyway this whole family
they represent so much of what's wrong
like just the money and the gross this
immediate media manipulation and all
this just like really just awful stuff
about commercialism and the way they
manipulate the media and use paparazzi's
while pretending to hate them
it's just all kind of gross and I think
it beautifully is summed up in this
giant wet glossy ass that you're looking
at right there